- [Narrator] This song
might be familiar to you.
♫ United States, Canada, Mexico, Panama
♫ Haiti, Jamaica, Peru
- [Narrator] Okay, well, listen to this.
♫ United States, Canada, Mexico, Panama
♫ Haiti, Jamaica, Peru
♫ Republic Dominican, Cuba, Caribbean
♫ Greenland, El Salvador, too.
♫ Puerto Rico, Colombia, Venezuela
♫ Honduras, Guyana, and still
- [Narrator] Rob Paulsen has a voice
that helped define ‘90s cartoons.
- Egad, Brain, brilliant!
- Okay, well, let's see, I'm Yakko Warner.
Hello, nurse!
I'm also Pinky from Pinky and the Brain.
And, uh, for those of you who
are fans of Jimmy Neutron,
I'm Carl, I'm the little fat guy.
- [Narrator] And you did
Raphael from the original
Ninja Turtles, right?
- Yeah, Raphael sounds a lot like me.
I say things like, "Shredder,
you tin-faced geek,
"get back here and taste
cold turtle steel!"
- Okay, we got a couple of
grade-A ding-dongs on our hands.
- [Narrator] And all the voices,
they have a background story.
- Oh no, I feel a flashback coming on.
- [Narrator] Let's go.
(cymbal crashes)
- [Robert] Where did the
inspiration for Pinky come from?
- We did it, narf!
We froze the giant!
- Well, for me, it was a large part
of my deep abiding love for British humor.
- Here's a little joke for you, Pinky.
Knock, knock.
- Well, that's not a
very funny joke, is it?
- Peter Sellers was a huge
inspiration, but, um, for some reason,
Mr. Spielberg and his infinite wisdom
decided it was a good fit
with Maurice LaMarche,
who was the Brain, so here we are.
(record scratching)
- [Narrator] Wait, Steven Spielberg?
Oh my God, there he is!
He produced Pinky and the Brain!
And Animaniacs?
Wait, wait, wait.
And he did Saving Private
Ryan, Twister, Men in Black,
and Schindler's List while
he was making these cartoons.
(blaring trumpets)
Okay, IMDB sidetrack over.
Sorry, back to Rob.
- Okay, great.
- [Narrator] Okay, so
Yakko from Animaniacs,
where did his voice come from?
- Only our hairdresser knows for sure.
- They decided on this little
sort of helium-based voice
that had kind of a smart-
ass vibe a la Groucho Marx.
Hey, Batman, does Dracula know
you're wearing his cape ...
so badly?
- [Narrator] And as for
the song where he sings
every country in the world?
- The interesting thing is it only took me
one take to record it.
The song is a beautifully crafted piece.
That's the difficult part, not singing it.
♫ Crete, Mauritania, then Transylvania,
♫ Monaco, Lichtenstein,
Malta and Palestine,
♫ Fiji, Australia, Sudan.
- [Narrator] Some other
places you can hear him
were in Goof Troop, Darkwing Duck,
Gummi Bears, Tiny Toon Adventures.
The list goes on.
This guy is kinda legend.
- I don't write 'em, and I don't draw 'em.
I'm just the singer.
But it is a cool thing to be
associated with those shows.
It's pretty cool, nobody
cares what I look like,
so I can do it as long as I can breathe.